oui c'est la rentrée mais je vous
reprends les vidéos jeux j'écris une
fuite à mes vidéos sur les jeux vidéo je
vous jouez pas spécialement le faire
mais vous avez été très nombreux à me
l'a demandé et puis j'ai fait une
rencontre assez douloureuse
il m'a donné envie d'en parler c'était
une meuf avec qui je discutais un moment
parler de jeux vidéo je racontais que je
jouais en moyenne une heure par jour sur
pc et sur consoles et elle m'a dit il
faut grandir un peu les jeux vidéo c'est
pour les petits enfants et là j'ai
regardé son téléphone
elle avait trois pages de jeu la meuf
ces journées c'est le latin 15 minutes
de candy crush à 12h15 de 2048 rentrer
en 15 minutes de rosen et le soir 15
minutes de temps paul rudd elle joue
autant que moi ah non mais moi c'est pas
des jeux vidéo c'est quoi alors qu'est
ce que c'est c'est des applications
c'est dans la catégorie jeux tu joues
sur un écran désolé de te l'apprendre
comme ça marlène mais tu joue à des jeux
vidéo ce à quoi elle m'a répondu c'est
sa ferme ta gueule
oh il ya un autre truc qui m'énerve pas
mal ce sont certains puristes qui jouent
sur pc quand tu cherches sur un forum
une aide pour choisir entre la xbox one
et la ps4
t'es sûr que le premier message va
parler de baisser les mecs veulent pas
répondre à la question mais ils
répondent quand même
j'hésite entre deux paires de chaussures
prenez un scooter ça va plus vite à
scooter je joue aussi sur pc mais pour
moi c'est impensable de ne pas avoir une
console je le vivrais trop mal les jeux
exclusifs sur consoles
c'est bon ça tu peux tu appelleras
d'entrée en fait c'est pas moi qui
décide je suis plus rien d'accord allez
bonne journée quand même au revoir les
jeux ça évolue tellement on a des trucs
de ouf aujourd'hui il ya des jeux de
rôle avec des cartes immenses avec un
nombre dingue de personnages le problème
c'est qu'ils ont qu une seule réplique
bonjour je cherche le château peut-être
que vous savez a mais là je vous dois
une fière chandelle
non mais ça va pas de problème sur les
dragons parents qui cherchent le château
voilà dublin je dois une fière chandelle
comment tu t'appelles ah ok je le
parlais à lui il est ultra relou il
répète tout le temps je le déteste j'ai
envie de brûler sa famille ouais je t'ai
bref cherche le château en fête fait
deux heures on m'a dit que c'était pas
mal parlé à lui il est extrêmement relou
et répète tout le temps je déteste j'ai
vraiment une brouille sa famille cdf
parler parler à lui il est extrêmement
relou a fait tout le temps d'ailleurs
dans les jeux de rôle japonais
ils font souvent un truc super bizarre
ça fait 25 ans qui font ça dans les jeux
quand tu sors du village tu fais la
taille du village au calme
excusez moi je cherche le château
regardez un géant ils nous attaquent
donc j'imagine que c'est pas idiot et le
château regardez un géant ils nous
attaquent
ah oui c'est vrai que vous aimez bien
répéter la même chose regardez un géant
voilà c'est beaucoup mieux un style que
j'aime bien même si je suis pas du tout
doux et c'est les jeux tiers les fps fps
ça joue sur pc et hagen pour les jeux de
tir s'est pas beaucoup plus crédible et
jeu drôle hein
les mecs change d'armes en oublie
seconde sera axée pratique souvent c'est
un peu on un coup de couteau
[Musique]
msm et c'est mon arme
bon par contre et commence à devenir un
petit peu prévisible surtout les
campagnes sous l'eau je sais
pertinemment privé avoir des ennemis je
sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il va se passer un truc les ennemis
dans les jeux de tir
ils sont tous cons à vouloir nous mettre
des trucs pour qu'on se protège on est
d'accord je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
bonne idée parce qu'on arrive en ligne
et on voit ce qu'elle regarde quoi j'ai
pensé un python de soul je te dis c'est
comme ça c'est d'un besoin de fioul on a
dû
les jeux d'aventuré aussi super
prévisible pour un truc tout con logo de
sauvegarde quand tu vois un logo de
sauvegarde
tu sais tout je sais qui va se passer un
truc
personne ne s'y attendait ouah je vois
bien un logo de sauvegarde dans ma vie
je suis preneur pourquoi pas sauvegarde
du shérif faut qu'on parle non il ya
deux mois j'ai rencontré quelqu'un il
est chirurgien et pompier volontaire non
non non non non pas aux jeux vidéo non
je n'en pense rien il est batteur dans
un groupe de rock je n'entends rien du
tout la lamal a reconnu qu'elle plaît je
redémarre eaux des lacs
[Musique]
ah voilà c'est mieux chérif aux faucons
par don meehan on l'a en fait c'est 4
millions de fans sur ma page facebook
merci beaucoup vraiment je vous donne en
échange une vie supplémentaire sinon il
ya un truc que j'adore dans les jeux
vidéo
je sais pas le faire